اراد هاري الخصوصيه لكنه لا يبدو متحفظا
على الكشف عن تفاصيل حياته وحياتي عائلته
الملكيه اراد الابتعاد عن الاضواء لكن بعد
مقابلات عده ووثائقيا هوليودي وكتاب مرتقى
لا يبدو ان رغباته او كلماته تتماشى مع
افعاله فماذا يريد الامير المتمرد
واخيه لكنه يضع الكره في ملعبهم لتولي
مهمه اعاده العلاقه الى صديقها
يريد عوده الامور الى مجارها مع الملك
تشارلز وولي العهد الامير ويليام لكنه لا
يتوانى عن كشف تفاصيل مزعجه عن اخيه الذي
تقع على عاتقه مهمه الحفاظ على ارث
العائله لاجيال القادمه
يزعم فيها هاري ان الامير وليام هجمه
جسديا في كتاب يتضمن تفاصيل الخلاف الشهير
بين الشقيقين عام 2019
من هذا الشهر باكثر من 16 لغه مختلفه
وكتاب صوتي سيكون قاسيا على وليام على وجه
الخصوص اذ يتهموه هاري بالاساءه الى زوجته
بعد نعتها بالصعبه والواقحه
حتى هيك مادلتون تتلقى نصيبها من
الانتقادات في الكتاب في حين اعفى هاري
الملك تشارلز من تعليقات مماثله وقبل
اصدار الكتاب بايام يقول هاري انه يرغب في
عائله وليس مؤسسه
الملكيه بتلاعب في قصص العائله وتسريباتها
هو يريد روايه جانبه من القصه وتجريد
المؤسسه الملكيه من حصريه روايتها ولكنه
مع كشفه لتفاصيل حساسه في كتابه المتوقع
يبدو ان الامير هاري مشغولا ببناء مهنه
الاعلاميه خارج قيود المؤسسه الملكيه
مخاطرا ربما بعائلته التي كما يقول يرغب
باستعادتها بشده من لندن لصباح العربيه